due ragazzi prova challenge con la ruota
delle sorprese delle torture e delle
ferite che già abbiamo detto che se
avete consigliato gatto e oggi come
sorprese abbiamo i tipi di origin al
cento per cento
lionel veneti chi mi ricordo ancora che
gli skifidol nel barile
sono tornata e sono anche profumati
esistono in the colori fluo e 6 schifo
in edicola in allegato alla rivista 2
euro e 99 quindi super preso io
conveniente quindi spero che la ruota
tutti lasciate un bel laiche
consigliateci altre più intense da fare
nei prossimi video con la ruota delle
sorprese e ora siete pronti mettetevi
con i famosi cantanti che allora primo
turno vediamo chi inizia calabrò che
posso fare punti ma ho mai tifato
passato ma cominciamo così
mi vedere dire hai tutte le pellicine di
fuori di manicure e stefan bell ross a
quello che fosse rosso magari sportivo
lisma il tramite di valentino si possono
[Musica]
e si toglie dai guai a barolo gigante di
vita ma che bello sullo smartphone a
papà curioso di vedere come ti starà
bene
ops è un po difficile mettere lo smalto
nelle tue unione di gaza
poi la posizione di quello come svolto
sulle rughe
vogliamo ridare poi vederli dell'ateneo
per il colore per fortuna non si vede
molto perché color carne
[Musica]
la casa attenzione viene fornita siamo
solo in bene ho anche messo sul piatto
allora la strada giusta di perdere
abbiamo 2 qual è quello chiaro quando
scuro secondo bene per me gara però che
io ho fatto il mio bianco di miele
questo a morte sì ma fa ripeto con il
suo smalto e un rimando maglia è
scappato bel giocatore di di un po
turchi che belli tg clip live tv la
prima quindi io già collezionato due
flight per colore verde dai verdi del
settore v termina con l'ispirato ancora
niente
io ho menzionato lo sguardo
online magari omega mi daranno 4 2 come
fanno capitano nemo un peperoncino e
normali abbiamo un peperoncino super
piccante sembra strano perché un po
sottile ma resta questi sono i più
piccanti e dai ma io non vado solo un
pezzettino perché questo fortissimo da
infortuni ne abbiamo l'acqua
no lo stand di niente tutti si stava
sentendo male ma va bene non vi
preoccupate davvero che lirica perché
così porterai che resta l'improvvisa
sale dotto insieme ti brucia tutto
lingua creola tutto viola è più che
bello allora vediamo un po d'ora infatti
un podista unendo tutti così faccio un
mega cicli slide tutto colorato che se
compro e melaverde che invece questo qua
e blu rosa quindi e rosa suo profumo di
scheggia vediamo
uno sciroppo fantastico vediamo un po
alimentazione wow
il colore bellissimo superfluo il
profumo fantastico perché diventano two
tier cavali nessuno è buono visto
qualcosa di simile jabu national party
lingua
ora vediamo il prossimo il prossimo anno
schifi colore schifo come si chiama
questo schifo smeraldo professore si era
aldo profumo di menta
dopo questo colore bellissimo
incentivino sentiamo il profumo si senta
100 acri già lamenta un bellissimo
perché momento cosa sembra proprio un
water slime anche l'atteso il colore che
andiamo chiaro che la mia colletta di di
slime finora un arcobaleno di vediamo se
li shan e sociali al 13 la rai sia
bellissimo line marcobaleno 2 bianco
lucido
quindi se già uscito devo guardare
quello più vicino quindi quello a fianco
quindi questo non è un sito quindi si
viola
potremmo davvero allora vedi o più bello
finalmente colore schifo allora questo
si viola viola con lo schifo
apriamo di colore mi sembra tipo lampone
barry sarebbe così bene nel mio tempo e
che dio ci fa bene con le mie unghie
colorate con la reginetta e poi il
secondo invece che blu è sempre uno
schifo blu vediamo vediamo magari saldi
di mare che buono se tipo di di che
bello il colore preferito di evitare che
blair libri regali donne io non le
voglio mischiare rapiti due colori
boschivi il mio volete che bello che sta
diventando turco baleno e stufe
prescritti sono bellissimi da unire
questo perché fanno tante sfumature
altrimenti per quello spirito racing e
venivo 10 ma anche perché mi piace poi
girarli fuori da un barattolo così il
mio ti rimando ai tuoi e da carmen sogno
di prendere altri toni
speriamo ci vengano dalla mise in salvo
mentre a destra
la fortuna non è capitato a mestre mette
al collo trani sarebbe stato meglio così
perché qui dai peli sconce soletta
imprendi che mi devi fare la ceretta
fresu scorso non muore non troppo labbra
palestrato aiuta
[Musica]
questo caldo così aderiscono gli siamo
grati 1 2 1 al 3 allora il tre fotografi
non ho preso molto non ha preso molti
impegni va bene dopo perché a buttare
tutto intero hanno calcato il mio
bellissimo remo tutto sfumato perché non
vi sia più
[Musica]
che cosa è proprio così quindi siamo
pari
il mio rain boot drive o un colore blu e
uno schifo allora chiama coloro cha e
lucidi rosa
[Musica]
roberto mi ha voluto per il colore di
questi plugin che profumo buonissimi che
bella mio lembo come si sta facendo bene
il mio visto che sono tutti i colori
quasi scuri tranne cosa quindi voi
neanche più perché vuoi avere una
sfumatura fatti luttuosi brosio può
giocare io no ma non tocca di due
impedito un atto che rinviene vediamo
questo rotta con loro e loro questo
errore
questo è colore blu
stati fragola devo che bello splendenti
queste stupide malato che ti ho detto
addio che mi ricordo di unire si chiama
bene allora mettiamo di base il rosa non
lo chiamo un po poi sopra cosa mettiamo
il blu laterale e poi mettiamo che sto
viola e questo rosso rilasciato un po
così e in pratica all'inizio rimangono
così però piano piano si uniscono e
fanno le strumento è bellissimo la tua
rainbow bellissimo non vedo l'ora di
vedere come diventerà anche
siamo pari a 44 per iniziare mamma è un
grande coordinamento no siamo pronti
abbiamo questa volta non fossero meglio
sentire che mi da allora il trentino è
[Applauso]
fatto male questa volta gruppo rimandare
al prossimo più vicino per questo quindi
già chi sta in voltaggio adesso che stai
importato di aiuto io ho votato io sto
in vantaggio e fiji vero che i prossimi
mi capiteranno a me le prossime udienze
di capiteranno 3a e presidente ci sono
la scuola slides in testa per un paio di
voglio giocare
provocare primo è un colore fluo giallo
fu nel suo profumo limone che buono lo
mettiamo proprio qui sul rosso così cool
ma che buon profumo gas mentre il vero
la cartolina verdolino chi vive profumo
ecco bravo schivi weber di tutti i
colori praticamente mi ha però il
bellissimo rainbow televisori colori più
forti con belle di altri non sa volare
più trova più belli ma che dobbiamo
mettere motivi capire poi se mi dispiace
è stato il mio slime sul tuo conto della
tratta in testa
io ho mangiato il peperoncino mi sono
messa nello smalto tour invece niente il
solo lo scotch come te lo tieni questo
diritto
ma vai pure un po troppo grande giornata
intensa che se avete accesso poi di
metterlo sua intensa se non poter
richiedere da un albero frattempo
guardare nelle sfumature quasi mi
dispiace mettono in testa abbiamo detto
di no
non so come fare
davvero
[Musica]
che casino
[Applauso]
[Risate]
comunque mi sporca
ricambio più slime tanti numeri cappelli
[Musica]
[Risate]
111 mm io mi prendo la menzione intanto
grazie e quindi alla fine siamo fare di
nuovo no del vantaggio ma io uso la
prima campeggiare aiuto superveloci nome
solo smalto che prendi vediamo presto
e questo il mio profumo di arancio
mandarino berlingò karate che bello
spendibili e allora tutti i frutti e
molto luzi nonché uno che mette
trasparentissimo manicardi arcobaleno
erano possiamo così invece perché uno
non voglio poter varare nel barattolo
perché mi piace comunque sto tuttifrutti
profuma benissimo buonissimo eccolo qua
quel lorenzo nel profumo di mandarino
lunghi tornio rainbow cioè bellissimo
quante sfumature è stupendo unirsi stein
fa delle sfumature fantastiche quello di
evitare deve ancora creare tutte le
sfumature perché l'abbiamo messo in
testa hanno creato tra le sfumature che
bello detto più per me questo bello
mai il profumo è fantastico di questo
tutti i frutti tra i bilanci per la mia
guardare nuovo fatto la casa non
mettetevi lo slime in testa siamo noi
che non si sbattono ma sarebbe meglio
ovvero la cultura si sono staccati dai
capelli perché sono belli zigrino nei pc
così quindi decisamente non sono
appiccicati altrimenti vi sarebbero
attacca per tutti ma che li trovate in
allegato alla rivista due ore 99 vi
consiglio assolutamente di unire i
colori perché escono queste sfumature
rosse che sui bellissimi ora lo conservo
così così un bellissimo rain boot di
glee slime fantastico e non so che un
bel laica questo minimo era mi lascia un
po a quanto accade da pubblicare per
vedere i nostri altri video ciao lancio
video divertenti scherzi casa su quella
che preferite